my favorite interviews at comic-con this
is always one of them the cast of
sharknado because they are off the chain
this is absolutely the craziest movies
in the world now they're coming to an
end what really is this the end is this
the end
who could say for sure the fact that
this movie got made in the first place
right it tells us that anything is
possible so is this the end looks like
every good thing eventually comes to an
end so I think as of now it will be an
end but who knows in 10 years it could
be a reunion of another sharknado hit
there is a definitive end in at the end
of this movie like it's there's no
cliffhanger so we can at least say
definitively the story that started in
sharknado one ends in sharknado 6 really
it comes full circle
oh yeah how they wrote it it's amazing
I hear that these sharks can travel
through time so clearly they're going to
get some folks there's a cauldron really
how're you getting the pipeline what is
this really good travel see the world in
a pot with the sharks from the Sharks we
Texas you can't already constrain your
students you don't think at all actually
no and they did it all how to put her
headset others would cut our heads off
and you just see is freezing like in
this thing we wanted to get out it could
be just a the pot I just I mean I smell
Oscar Emmy this is this here can we talk
about this how long did it take I don't
know I wasn't there when they did
as across the town you're across town do
it on well no I actually woke up this
way okay so give me some of the cameos
that we can expect because there are all
these crazy cameos I mean just crazy yes
guy we have Alaska Deborah Wilson Snider
and I get to play Billy the Kid which is
the coolest but like when they call my
cage do you want to play Billy the Kid
and you want to ride a horse shoot guns
in the Wild West as sharks you're like
absolutely and here's like getting
cheese a horse yeah it's crazy go back
to get Billy the Kid yeah yep you ride
dinosaurs pterodactyl yeah she calls her
Tara who else we're gonna get to see cuz
now I'm excited
Marina Marina Sirtis she played right
track
she plays your mother she yammin is
George Washington and I'm so funny I
know - oh no and we got Tori Spelling
yeah so it's basically half the cast of
a reunion so it's very exciting
oh my gosh yeah yeah so Leslie Jordan
okay clearly you've taught y'all he I
could not believe
we go back in time where Steve we go
back in time where Finn meets his
parents and Finn's mom is played by Tori
and his dad is played by Dean so it's
kind of like a little twist of reality
great yeah and this see a night I was
with him in it is that sport and I was
like wow I mean yes the toilet acts
couldn't afford you I got tears : I
thought she wanted me to come interview
yeah no okay so here's what I wanna know
did you take something from the set when
it ended when it was over that last
scene what was that goodbye like I took
a pair of thermals I was last one
shooting hold it was like minus 30 like
I've never been so cold you were shaking
half the time like how Clues here alive
we asked him our faces were competing
they really 6% rate experice her pants
on six jackets on six zeros either to
dilute it I didn't care what other
things had to be rewritten to include
them getting close along the way from
this insane journey what will you take
away and what was the craziest death in
all of sharknado the craziest the crate
each one of you I want you to each one
of you to tell us the crit you're crazy
sharknado moment when you were like this
is clearly jump the shock Terence always
Wow hey all the sharknado movies has
been in such an incredible fun
experience I mean we ever know one never
knew it was gonna turn out to be what it
was in male became a family yeah but
when it came to the shark killings which
there's a lot of there's been a lot of
games about them as well yeah but I
would say one of my favorite ones was a
Kelly Osbourne in the secular on the
airplane that was a pretty good shock
that um my favorite shirt kill was
standing on top of the fire truck in
Manhattan in sharknado 2 I leaned back
and held up this 45 pound chainsaw and
let the shark fly through it only
because as it was written in the script
fin waves chainsaw in here there's no
waves like a 50 pound chance anyway you
can't wave this thing through the air so
I said hey I'm just gonna lean back in
the artists are gonna draw the fish
going through and it's gonna be fine
years ago okay artists what do you mean
the Sharks are real favorite day
actually I think one of my favorite
overall death sequences is in number
three when we go to space I am goes into
a shark with spacesuit and a chainsaw
good uses it to play I'm looking into
the top and uses a parachute from here
to there
moved me and I'm like this is ridiculous
it can't be that long cut it ridiculous
I mean my favorite death would have to
be mine which is the best in all the
sharknado movies I have to say I can't
tell you what it is you're gonna have to
watch it to find out guys what is it as
Billy the Kid of course Billy the Kid
yes okay yes that's true but you're
gonna have to watch it to find out guys
I think in sharknado 3 Lucas I think you
mean as his character
because her harm is still alive I ever
had to see like something is still
working well looks like this we clear at
the end the sharknado 5 he destroyed the
world this is a last man on earth and
he's walking the ends of the earth with
Tara's head in a hobo sack dang that's
how we end up and then you pick up
because you all figured out yeah he's
still alive but he's in a different
dimension
shooting one day he's like okay and now
you're driving this sharknado I'm
driving the sharknado yeah you could
sear it so no on a steering a sharknado
I'm like what is this gotten to you like
breaking it number Blue Zones I mean it
was just this one was just by far I
think it's the best one laughs what is
your favorite well I don't want to give
anything away but my favorite part was
the really tasteful nude love seeing
those are the greatest eyelashes I've
ever seen every year here
sharknado pulls off a major stock what
is this thought this year I had the
Chuck nails gonna pull off at comic-con
mm we usually we have the shark girls
out that we have yeah something really
goes crazy in the street I think there's
definitely be a couple of pop up yeah
we're putting a fin on Alaska
we haven't indigo we haven't hit the
streets yet we don't know what's going
on out there
yeah and by the way how much do you love
comic-con and when you get down this for
us say is this gonna be our last
comic-con like we're still used to this
six years in a row no way my wife I just
love this I'm coming every dress outside
it's so fun one it's like it's a very
melancholy kind of feeling like this is
really young like she's my Valentines
Day everybody shoot drink yeah by the
way Mean Girls reunion amanda says she's
in for it I'm in for it
are you yeah I want to do the Broadway
show boys are not a good singer or
dancer stars like third America voted
I'm not gonna dancing I'm okay with that
so Sharpedo
when does it air let everybody know
August 19th on Sci Fi
I mean it has been a joy and in
comic-con will not be the same without
you but I know you're gonna make
something up in your be back here next
year please come back sharknado fans out
there thanks everybody
[Music]